僕が
周りの人を喜ばせるわけこちらの話をし
たいと思います
一つの出会いと3つの大きな壁が僕の人生
のターニングポイントになりました
1967年
僕は4人兄弟の末っ子として生まれました
左は死です
父はですね
昭和2年生まれなので
昭和1桁っていうと多分
すごい武骨で
怖そうな
イメージがあると思いますけども
全く動かないめちゃくちゃ優しい父親でし
た4人兄弟の中でもたまにまだあまり
起こらなかったねっていう話するぐらい
すごい優しいしでした
とその母親との
両親の
温かい愛情に包まれて僕は
両親が大好きな子供になりました
高校3年生の時に大きな壁が1つ
現れます
それは
色弱です
もともと色弱は小学校の頃から検査では
わかってました
高校3年生の時に
就職活動をします
父親の職業は
電車の運転手でした
僕も電車の運転手がとても大好きでなり
たい職業でした
その時に鉄道会社に就職するために
話を進めているときに
鉄道会社の方から
色弱の人は
運転手になれないという話になりました
僕は大変落ち込みました
夢がちょっと崩れたという感じがして
すごい落ち込んでいたんですがその時に
父親はこういうふうに言ってくれました
色弱で
運転手になれないんだったら
就職しなくていいから
藤尾は好きな大学に行きなさいというふう
に
言ってくれました
好きな大学行っていいんだと思って
色弱がきっかけで僕は
進学の道に行けることになります
当時映画が大好きだったので
映画が勉強できる大学が一つあったので
そこを受験して見事に
不合格
撃沈
まぁもう一個で言ってたんでそこに行った
時の
写真がありますもう4年間の集大成ですね
こちらが
集大成です
まあ普段からこんな風に
歩いてたわけではないんですけどもこれは
あの
友達と一緒に街に寝る歩いたりとかまあ
もともとこういうふうに
好きなことを
喜んでもらうのは少し好きな学生ではあり
ましたまあキャンパスライフは最高に
楽しくてそのまま就職しますね
広告代理店に入りましたこれ絶頂です絶頂
期にしてもあれですよ
ヘアスタイルのことじゃないですよ
ねでそのままイェーゲどんどん1年間を
失望しますでその時に会社からとある
プロジェクトの話が上がります
長野県の松本市に
営業所を立ち上げるので
東京から1人誰か行けないかということが
ありました私は猪まで行きますということ
で行きましたね
どうですか
長野
ちょっとバブルの
香りプンしますよねしますちょっと
目をつぶって
吸ってみますか
しました
ありがとうございますね
拍手いただきありがとう少し落ち着きまし
た
これはですね
ナウなヤングにバカウケのスキー場でした
ねこれ多分白馬かと思いますただこの長野
県で
第2の壁が現れますそれは
うつです
打つというのは僕の中では一番
世の中で全然
使い物にならなくて
自分自身が
ずっと嫌いだと思ってるのが
うつ病です
さて僕はどうして打つになってしまったん
でしょうか
仕事のミスからでした
当時
メーカーの仕事でパンフレットを5万部
する仕事がありました
5万部印刷して
納品をしてそのサンプルを見た瞬間に
愕然としましたね
写真が違う
倍加持ちが文字もしがもう全然違う
ほとんどパンフレットとしては使い物に
なりませんでした
その時に
当時の
担当者はカンカンに送るわけですねでその
時に僕にこういうふうにいます
林さんパンフレット5万ブスってるんです
から
林さんパンフレットは5万人5万人の人が
パンフレット見るんですよですから林さん
は
5万人の責任を取ってくださいと言われ
ました
その時から5万人の責任でどう取るん
だろうと思って
仕事の帰りからずっと悩み続けます
とりあえず1から5万数えてみたりとか
あとはパンフレット見た人があこれ売買が
違ってるメーカーに電話なんですフレーム
に出てそのクレームが僕のところに来て
それが長野中
謝って回らなきゃいけないのかなとそんな
ことを考えながら
ずっと仕事をしていくうちに
僕は
全然仕事ができなくなってしまいました
完全な鬱です
ちなみに
5万人というのは
札幌ドーム
満員に超前にすると5万人だそうですです
から僕はその5万人の責任いやいくらなん
でもあの大きさの人数はやはり責任は取れ
ないなと思ってます
そこから
東京に戻されます
営業も外されて
僕は完全なお荷物になってしまいました
大した成果も上げられずに
東京のところでずっと仕事をする毎日でし
たただ唯一その時に
救いだったのは
フィットネスです
フィットネスクラブかよって
トレーニングをして
有酸素を出しますこんな感じですね
エアロビスですエアロビスわかりますこう
やってやりながらやるんですよこういうの
こういうのやるとですねわかると思います
けど今日はできないかもしれません
汗とか書いてすごいいろんなものがね
突っ飛びますよね
すごい楽しくてしょうがなかったです
自分は
楽しいフィットネスという自分がいて
打つで打ちひしがれて
仕事してる自分がいました
どうしても楽しい方で仕事をしたいと思う
ようになったら
こっちの仕事にしようと思って僕は
フィットネストレーナーになることを決め
ます
フィットネスのおかげで自分を取り戻す
ことができましたそこからは
昼は
広告の仕事
夜は
フィットネストレーナーの
学校に通います
その時に
心配してくれた人たちがたくさんいました
それは
道化のみんなです
道化のみんなはこういうふうに言います
せっかくいい会社に入って
これから一緒に仕事をしていこうというの
になんでフリーランスで
安定のしない仕事をやるんだともう少し
元気になったら一緒に仕事をしようと
すごい励ましてくれましたそれはすごい
嬉しかったですただなんか腫れ物に触られ
てるような
感じがして
少し申し訳ないなって気持ちでしたあとは
自分も今の環境をガラッと変えて
うつを知られてない自分で
再スタートしたいと思ってもいました
ほどなく僕は会社を辞めて
フィットネストレーナーになります今まで
電車の運転手にもなれがなかったしあと
行きたい大学も行けなかったのでようやく
なりたいというものになりましたここから
またいけいけどんどんですねとにかく
楽しくて仕方ないいろんなとこ行って
いろんなスポーツクラブ行って3年後は
こんな仕事をしてもっと違う仕事して
こんなたくさんの仕事して
下手したらもう世界中回ろうかなってもう
流れやってましたその時に1つの出会いが
あります
とあるおばあちゃんがエアロビクスの
クラスに
参加してくれました
60分間のクラス
多分彼女は
初めてだったと思います
初めてエアロビクス受けたおばあちゃん
大体80歳ぐらいの人だと思いましたけど
も
頑張って受けてもらいました
受けてもらって最後まで頑張ってもらい
ましたで最後まで残ってました
その時に声かけたんですねおばあちゃんお
疲れ様でしたどうでしたって言った時に
彼女はこう言いました最初は辛かったです
けど最後は
幸せでした
この仕事って
相当いい仕事なんじゃないかなと思ったん
ですいろんなことを考えていろんなことを
したいと思ってたけどもこの一瞬の一言で
僕は
フィットネストレーナーをずっとやろうと
思ってましたそして28年間
ずっと続けていますしこれからも続けて
いくつもりです
えっとそこから
僕は
第3の壁が現れますこれは
癌です
去年の
秋にわかりました
とても
ショックでどうして僕がっていうふうには
思い続けてました
鬱の場合はいつもなんかいつもこう
生きていたくないとか
信頼しに行ったりとかそんなこと考えて
ました
がんになるとですね今の僕の気持ちは
生きていたんだけどもしかしたら
ちょっと死ぬかもしれないなとかそんな
ことを不安になることが1日に何回か
起こりますそんな状況で過ごしてます一番
ちょっとつらいなと思ってるのが
先生との
診察です
診察するときにやはり凹むんですね
いろんなこと言われるのででその時僕考え
たんですよ
この診察も凹むのでもっとなんか
楽しくならないかなと思った時にあそうだ
ドクターをちょっと喜んでもらおう喜ばせ
たらいいんじゃないかと思って
僕は診察するときに必ず
イラストを描いて臨みました
ちなみにこれ
表に出すようなものではなかったんです
けどまあざっくり書いただけなんでこんな
ものにイラストを書いて
提案して
色々話したりしました
ドクターは大変に喜んでくれました
手術入院の時で退院の時にももうここに
いる皆さんから知り合いの皆さんからも
応援もいただいたんですが最後の日病室で
このイラストを書き上げて
病室はそこの
ナース
ドクターとても喜んでくれました大部屋
だったんでそこにいた患者さんもとても
喜んでくれて
すっごい病気が病室が楽しくなったのを
覚えてます
癌になる前の自分っていうのは
自分がもっと人に知られたいとか
有名になりたいとかビジネスをこんな
大きくしたいとかそういうことばっかり
考えてました
今
ガーになって思うのは今そこにいる人に
一緒に楽しめればいいと思うようになって
きましたがんという病気が
自分を大切にするっていうことを教えて
くれた気がしています
背伸びをしないで
好きなことだけをする生き方に
変わってきてます
ここで
実は
感謝したい人がいますそれは36年前に
亡くなった
自分の母です
母はいつも
口癖のように言ってました
他人のために時間を使うこと
他人のために
動いてあげることが
自分のためになるんだっていうのが口癖
でした
僕はその当時1819なのでそんなこと
言っても自分の人生だから自分のために
使うんじゃないのかっていう話をずっと
唯一続けますそれでも母はいつも笑ってい
ました
でも今ここで話してることってそういう
ことなんですよね
母親の気持ちがちょっとわかってきた気が
します
大きな壁にぶつかった時には
乗り越えるのも大事なんですけどちょっと
後ろに下がって
道を探してみるのもありだと思います
僕が
就職活動で打ちひしがれた時に
血の父親が
進学の道を開いてくれたように
何かに行き詰まったりしたら
環境を変えてみるのも大事だと思います
景色が
変わります
僕が
フィットネストレーナーになった時のよう
に
そして
自分を大切にしてくださいどんなことが
あっても自分を許してあげてください
そして自分の可能性を信じてください今
がんである自分がそういうふうに思って
いるといけないそしておばあちゃんに
幸せでしたって言われたあの時のように
目の前にいる人に何か
喜んでもらえることを
始めてみてあげてください
そうすれば
素敵な未来が
待ってるはずですありがとうございました
ありがとう